Katie likes to go to the store.
She likes to shop.
She goes to the bookstore with her mom.
She shops for a book.
She likes going to the food store with her dad.
She likes shopping for food.
She goes to the toy store with her grandfather.
She buys a toy.
She goes to the clothing store with her mom.
She looks for a coat.
She likes going to the shoe store with her grandmother.
She buys new shoes.
She goes to the pet store.
She looks for a pet.
Katie likes the pet store best.
She buys a puppy.
What does your sister like to do?
She likes to shop for food.
What else does your sister like doing?
She likes going to the bookstore.
Does she also like to go to the toy store?
Yes, she likes buying a toy.